since 2014 a working group has been
developing proposals for the
rehabilitation of the Copper River today
we're opposite the new Coast Guard
building just downstream of the William
Street bridge there never were must say
it looks fabulous across the river here
you can see a lot of hard work gone into
making it look beautiful can you tell me
please what happening with support
equality here yeah well right up and
down the river with everything we've
talked about so far it's all about
trying to just take small steps to
enhance the water quality as you know
you know we've got things flowing into
the water that need to be a lot cleaner
than they are there's influences from
upstream there's the pushback from the
way nucka dedi we need to make sure that
every step we take enhances the water
quality of this river and that's will
ultimately we want to go we want to make
sure that this river is cleaned up it is
in a shocking state making no bones
about that it is absolutely shocking and
it needs rehabilitation unfortunately
it's the long game not the short game
and we have to carry on just doing step
by step to make sure that we can try and
get some better water quality in here
[Music]
now I understand there's going to be
some regions taking places it's tough
going to be here or hair is that all
going to be so this is obviously the
area that's navigated by boats in and
out of here and we're they'll park and
we're they'll leave from or comes to so
that there will be a channel through
here one of the other sediment traps we
talked about earlier could possibly be
the actual Wharf area itself so when it
comes to read ridging a gift the wharf
area itself will be one of the main
dredging points as opposed to dredging
the whole river the river deepness past
the court in extreme which is the
confluence down down stream from here
which will also be planted in a manner
that you saw up there on the corner that
will also play a big part in the
navigation through here so it'll be
threads down under there the depth of
the water is probably not too bad from V
ramen through to the Y market ed so he
often people have their space well right
here they can come and there'll be an
open day at the royalton offer and
people can have their input that way we
have the website we have counselors
community board members and we really
want people to have their importance
there are six proposals we'd like your
feedback on attendee our open day on the
twenty-seventh of april we'll find out
more at Womack led dot govt TMZ